volodymyr zelensky qui annonce par
ailleurs que sa famille est toujours à
kiev elle n'a pas été exfiltré face aux
menaces russe bruno daroux c'est vrai
que le président ukrainien la ses
preuves dans son froid à toute épreuve
oui on en parle
peut-être pas suffisamment d'ailleurs
mais la tenue en fait du président
ukrainien dans cette crise qui aurait de
quoi paniquer beaucoup de chefs d'état
et est plutôt exemplaire on se souvient
que il a réitéré à plusieurs fois la
nécessité de ne pas paniquer donc ça
c'était un message à la fois dressé à sa
population et aussi aux chancelleries
occidentales d'ailleurs il a regretté
tout à l'heure que certaines
chancelleries
notamment américaines et canadiennes
aient décidé de de bouger leurs
représentations diplomatiques de kiev
vers l'ouest du pays donc en fait oui il
est resté très serein disant qu'il
fallait tout faire pour continuer le
dialogue avec moscou aujourd'hui il ya
eu des échanges avec la biélorussie donc
un ton à la fois si vous voulez
assez ferme mais aussi assez serein
alors assez fermes sur le fait que
l'ukraine reste droit dans ses bottes si
je puis dire
l'ukraine estime qu'elle est un pays
souverain et qu'elle a donc le droit de
demander son adhésion à l'otan ce qui
garantirait effectivement son intégrité
territoriale après ce serait de toute
façon compliqué d'abord parce qu'on sait
que la russie y est fermement opposé
mais même parce que là il parler
d'intégrité territoriale en fait
l'internet et territoriales à cause de
ce café vladimir poutine depuis 2014
n'existe plus à 100% puisque la crimée a
été annexé le donbass est tenu par des
séparatistes pro russes dont 6 l'ukraine
rejoigne l otan que ce qui se passerait
bien évidemment l'otan chercherait à
rétablir l'intégrité territoriale de
l'otan essarts créé de la tension et
moscou le sait parfaitement mais on peut
saluer quand même le fait que ce
président evans qui a un qui est plutôt
pro occidental et bien réitère le fait
que son pays est souverain et qu'il a le
droit dans l'absolu de faire ce qu'il
veut et que ça ne se décide pas à moscou
la situation sur le terrain à présent
bruno on va regarder une carte c'est
toujours très tendue à la russie a
littéralement cercle l'ukraine elle a
mené samedi des manoeuvres en mer noire
donc au sud elle amassé à l'est plus de
cent mille soldats à la frontière avec
l'ukraine et puis au nord moscou eu
également des exercices militaires avec
la biélorussie mais nous dit-on
certaines manoeuvres militaires sont en
train de s'achever c'est le ministre
russe de la défense qui le dit cet après
midi faut-il y voir un signal à écouter
on est peut-être au moment de vérité de
cette crise qui dure quand même depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'ils étaient
toujours en deux temps à la fois
poursuite du dialogue un vladimir
poutine n'a jamais rompu le dialogue ni
avec les dirigeants européens ni avec le
président américain et en même temps
cette tension qui n'arrêtait pas de
grimper donc on voit là le le dispositif
effectivement des troupes russes qui
littéralement encerclent l'ukraine donc
ça commence pas par évidemment la crimée
qui est donc annexée là c'est près du
donbass et ça remonte effectivement
jusqu en biélorussie avec les exercices
conjoints donc en fait c'est peut-être
aussi le moment de vérité pour vladimir
poutine parce que là il a mis le maximum
c'est à dire que ses troupes sont en
état de pouvoir pénétrer en ukraine
logistiquement tout est prêt mais
maintenant il doit prendre des plus
grandes décisions de sa vie de deux
chefs d'état ou de chef de gouvernement
à la tête de la russie parce que là
effectivement comme dit bruce johnson il
est un peu au bord du précipice il a
fait monter la tension la tension la
tension il a continué parallèlement à
discuter mais sans rien obtenir
finalement parce que ce que veut obtenir
l'otan la non adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan absolument garanti il ne
l'obtiendra pas d'eau maintenant il doit
décider ce qu'il va faire et sans doute
at-il sous-estimé dans cette crise
finalement la détermination de l'otan
des européens et des américains parce
qu'il comptait sur la faiblesse des
européens sur la le fait que les
américains n'avaient pas mourir pour
kiev en quelque sorte et finalement
qu'est ce qu'on observe quand on prend
un peu de recul et bien que c'est que
l'otan était très unis les européens
malgré quelques petites divisions de
minimes affiche quand même un bloc assez
unis et ont préparé tout un paquet de
sanctions économiques et donc vladimir
poutine là c'est son heure de vérité à
lui parce qu'il sait très bien que si
l'envahît d'ukraine il y aura des
répercussions notamment économiques
très forte dont peut-être que finalement
cette fermeté occidental qui n'était pas
acquise pour lui le contraint là à être
plus souple et il fait dire par son
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov qu'il ya toujours une chance pour
négocier effectivement très intéressant
le ministre russe de la défense qui dit
pour la première fois depuis le début de
la crise que certaines opérations
militaires sont en train de se terminer
d'autres vont l'être dans quelques jours
dos encore un peu plus importante donc
voila mais enfin le ton est en train de
changer à moscou il y avait aussi les
russes l'avait reconnu le fait que avec
les américains il pouvait discuter
d'autres sujets que celui de l'otan mais
les rues jusque là considéré ça comme
des sujets secondaires là ils sont en
train de dire on m'a finalement si on
discute de l' équilibre de la sécurité
sur le continent européen ce sera pas
mal il est en train de se passer quelque
chose sur cette prise d'ukrainiens merci
beaucoup bruno on suit bien sûr cette
situation de très près